having started off with the Syrian
refugees it gave us the captive audience
of people who wanted to make a
difference who contribute in a positive
way we decided to duplicate the exact
same framework for the Fort Mac evacuees
right now everybody's in the same boat
they left their house with nothing they
got evacuated out of their city they
weren't prepared so they have the
clothes on their back the Syrian couple
who we had delivered them a hamper at
Christmas time and they actually on
saturday came and delivered six hampers
to Fort Mac I believe it's just as
therapeutic to pack and and give to
hamper as it is to receive one
you